hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to 60 seconds now I
know the way to win I know the strategy
with which I can get this done and
apparently I've been doing something
very wrong that you guys have been
pointing out but it's a small minut
detail that you wouldn't actually think
would be a part of this that would be
very important for me to do and also
I've been practicing in the off hours
and I've gotten quite good at being able
to get my lovely family to safety
so the main point is there are spiders
and there are spy I'll get to witness I
got I can't explain now I got a run
where's that survival manual there it is
that's what I needed
[ __ ] I don't even have the map nothing
ain't got nothing no cards no nothing is
terrible oh good I got like nothing I
got nothing this was [ __ ] this is
[ __ ] this is [ __ ] it's just
[ __ ] with me it's [ __ ] this is a
load of ass and I don't appreciate loads
of ass ok now that we're in the basement
I'll tell you the secret stratagem to
make this victorious one have incredible
good luck this game likes to Fabri knock
you all over the place but to keep all
spiders alive because they are more
important than you know and also be sure
that mary jane is alive and well because
there is a small chance that when you
keep the spiders alive they'll bite Mary
Jane and turn her into a horrifying
mutant monstrosity that's gonna lead you
to victory because she when mutated is
completely invulnerable to everything
and only needs water I don't remember
but it's ok so with that being said we
are going to be plowing forward and
you're going to see me win this game no
matter what aah day two spiders seem to
be operating under the assumption that
they all the same rights to this shelter
as we do they're everywhere and don't
seem very scared of us it's time we
changed that or not everything's fine we
don't need to worry about
spiders oh dammit they didn't do the
thing ah man
well I guess since the spider event
already happened and I didn't get Mary
Jane to turn into a mutant I guess I can
go with the assumption that it's not
gonna happen from now on so I can just
start it over again so what I'll do is
I'll start a game and then I'll go until
I get to the spiders and see if they do
anything and if they don't I just have
to start over again until I lose my mind
everything is insane in my brain yes
tough luck a [ __ ] I didn't get the water
I'm going to grab that last water but I
think we did pretty good we got just
about every item except maybe the
flashlight and the lock I don't recall
getting those but I think I got most of
the entertainment stuff I got all these
Sancho's I got everything we needed
right then the of food in our butts we
are going to have lots of lots of food
it is good we're not going crazy what we
will is really really cool Timmy can go
out into the wilderness right from the
beginning Timmy Timmy is that his name
Timmy Timmy Timmy hey Timmy is able to
go out into the wilderness with a gas
mask early on to be able to scrounge up
a whole bunch of stuff because the
Little Boy Scout is the best of
scavenging welcome back to him Tim ones
gettin you got a flashlight and no water
great good job
that's gonna help
was real good dick but it dillhole what
a Dell we'd Hall I really hope the dog
doesn't come back before we get a medkit
because that never ends well
oh boy mushrooms give them to Mary Jane
maybe something's gonna happen
B Nobi just got sick
what a dick let's stick him in the Frick
Wow Timmy's back and we got oh we got a
med kit is this mean we're going to V
cougar oh that's a good Tim Tim Annie
got a med case really good now yes yes
yes
Annie's isn't time for everyone to get a
meal nice
no no pancake crawled back to us but
he's severely injured the poor thing has
been shot by some monster we need to
help and fast we're gonna help oh I've
never been able to help
oh what a clutch move yeah Oh chica be
go oh my goodness oh it makes me feel so
much better about everything Oh cutie
pie pancake how are you doing I mean
Ted's probably gonna die real soon but
yeah whatever it's okay they're all
fatigued but pancakes doing so good oh
it took a while but we were able to
patch pancake up we're not letting him
go this time do you know what love is we
sure know loving your dog okay so we
need hmm we're not certain about the
situation but we need dad would die if
you went out Mary Jane's feeling
excellent apparently but Timmy's only
been the best one and Delores can go
she's a little tired but that's okay
it's the army again we thought they were
near but it seems that something kept
him away we're not leaving just yet the
broadcasts request for assistance they
want us to figure a few cancers a gas to
the nearest bus stop needed for
transport oh okay
whoo I don't know why this is important
for the rescue but maybe we're actually
gonna do something about this I have no
idea
I'll set the canisters are in place and
we're safely back home well if you can
call it that and hopefully for not too
long we will see the next few days bring
loris you're going out there go the gas
masks good luck I just just so happened
to just use that it would be a good idea
to let pan kick out for a while he's dog
he needs his space for running and other
things so how about we send him outside
for a while yeah okay maybe you can get
us something he survived that long
without us I'm sure he'll be fine with
hey Delores welcome back you look good
you got water
Oh perfect one water only one water oh
that was pancake dog paws are no good
for carrying bottle Wow nice job and two
more water
nice nice nice okay so I don't know when
Timmy's gonna be better but I'm gonna
hold off Delores is not looking any
better day we should fix her up soon did
we take the first-aid kit
Dolores what's wrong with Dolores what
Dolores is fine it's dead that's bad
that's a bug that's a bug if I ever saw
one Oh Dolores Sutton look so good
anymore well then all right
poor poor Dolores we're not optimistic
Dolores was fine just a little bit okay
the military just wind us to go outside
and outline their situation I probably
should have sent up nope Ted's dead dad
died dad died we managed to make it to
the meeting in time we tried our best to
answer the soldier asked his questions
let's hope we fulfilled their
expectations and a ragged appearance
didn't make a bad impression
well Ted's dead great that's a good
impression to make he literally got
there and then he collapsed great oh
whoa whoa okay well all right then
that's okay bye well all right then I
guess I guess we were done here anyway
we didn't turn Mary Jane into anyone but
uh I have a funny feeling that we were
pretty close to being rescued unless
just why did they both get sick that
didn't make any sense Dolores
just got sick and like preemptively was
like hey Dolores ain't looking so good
did you get a medkit I'm like she looks
fine and no oh now she's gonna die
have fun great if you were curious why
there's a red blood handprint it's
because I raided a retirement home and
stole food from all people I'm a good
person so we're going down a dark path
but we need to survive it's a ghost and
Timmy's been gone a long time
Timmy we thought you were dead you're
sick
god dammit oh oh oh the group of doctors
and lab coats came over and they gave us
injections we're all cured every one of
us got cured how convenient
well that's good too bad we're headed
down the dark path to darkness we could
really use some more supplies we counted
all of them today and the numbers did
not make us happy time to do something
about it we know that a teacher from the
local school managed to rescue a bunch
of kids and lead them to a nearby
building where they're relatively safe
and we could really use whatever they
have we could really use it right yeah
we could okay I guess this is how we're
gonna survive huh
well no more bloody handprints but I
think we got more supplies we had no
idea that installed some kind of alarm
ah god damn it soon as we tried to open
it we were jumped and attacked with
Lucifer Dixon map pointers there are way
too many adults we were expecting just
one teacher but it turns out they left
children behind to make space for
themselves we are appalled those
terrible terrible teachers ah
everyone's evil we know there's a group
of bandits cam near our shelter but
we're not exactly powerless with a bit
of luck and force maybe we can children
we're not to be trifled with
yeah take some of this we're gonna get
you
and maybe we got him I don't know did we
get him we performed a very tactical
maneuver and sneak towards the camped in
broad daylight without any cover it soon
turned out that no such maneuver ah
that's right bandits were fighting a
group of giant mutated spiders and
nobody was guarding the supplies whew
we got an axe good for us we're great oh
hi hello how's it going what's going on
hey okay all right then
shouldn't open that door that was my
mistake I did a bad then I got destroyed
by Raiders I should know open that door
okay then we were doing moderately okay
not too well there we go there that's a
new screen I've died two bandits anyway
I've been playing about 45 minutes
trying to get this Mary Jane thing to
happen but at least we got pancake that
was good I mean it's something right but
I guarantee in the next episode I will
win no matter what I will win
I guarantee it I'm gonna get Mary Jane
and this is gonna happen I guarantee it
so thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always I will see you